[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
n'oubliez jamais d'une crise politique
économique religieuse pour que les
droits des femmes soient remis en
question ces droits ne sont jamais
acquis vous devrez rester vigilante
votre vision cette semaine le dow
c'est presque une tarte à la crème et
c'est terriblement de qualité pourtant
j'ai choisi de m'engager sur ces
thématiques
ces thématiques qui m'intéresse depuis
tout petit
mais j'aimerais bien un moniteur à
simone de beauvoir
parce que franchement si le féminisme
c'est travailler sur les mêmes
thématiques toute ma vie durant
alors le féminisme ce n'est pas un
engagement c'est une tâche sisyphe et
j'aimerais bien que cet engagement soit
plus qu'une guerre froide où il faut
être sur le qui-vive en permanence
j'aimerais bien aussi qu'on arrête de
décrédibiliser régulièrement le
féminisme en le présentant comme une
simple guerre des sexes
au début ce concept même de guerre des
sexes
je viens danser même pas pour moi
c'était un concept absolument absurde
qu'est ce que ça veut dire la terre des
sexes n'a pas grand chose
oui il ya une guerre des idées
éventuellement au moins neuf sous le
soleil
et puis la croix-rouge lampard lennon
entendre parler font une demande dans un
cas le personnel professionnel le
prendre position sur cette thématique
je me suis finalement ça valait
peut-être le coup d'abord des sujets ne
serait ce que pour le désamorcer je suis
persuadé qu'il est absolument nécessaire
de sortir de cette logique binaire genre
et qui conditionne à la fois notre
identité mais aussi nos idées on sera
toujours en danger
cette guerre des sexes artificielle aura
toujours un terreau fertile
tant qu'on continuera à s'identifier en
premier lieu à leur sexe et notre jambes
alors sortir des stéréotypes changer de
mentalité évidemment ça passe par
l'éducation
ça passe aussi par des choses toutes
simples du quotidien
arrêtez d'utiliser ces phrases tout
c'est vous
the only flammes qui ont l'air innocent
comme ça ne me sont pas comme ça et je
sais que c'est plus facile à dire qu'à
faire moi même en étant engagés sur ces
questions il m'arrive encore
régulièrement de dire des choses comme
bien sûr que je sais faire deux choses à
la fois je suis pas un mec quand même
merci voilà bon cliché donc dire il faut
arrêter de jeunesse qui n'a pas besoin
d'être genre et ça ne veut pas dire pour
autant que gommer les différences
alors je précise parce que c'est ça
aussi c'est une question qu'on me pose
régulièrement et j'ai l'impression que
cette peur de la guerre des sexes va
avec cette peur de la fin du genre pour
moi sont tout aussi infondées donc que
l'autre mais c'est important de dire que
non au contraire il ya bien des sujets
genre et qui au contraire n'ont pas été
abordés pendant trop longtemps qu'ils
ont été regardées avec un petit peu de
des normales je pense notamment à la
douleur des femmes
ce qu'on voit actuellement avec
l'endométriose toucherait 5 à 10% des
femmes même d'une manière plus large les
règles en fait c'est encore un sujet
tabou on en parle pas suffisamment quand
on est au bureau qu'on a mal à la tête
aucun problème à voir un collègue c'est
un joli pran super ou et merci
quand on parle des règles c'est un autre
sujet et ça contribue au fait de
d'apprendre femmes justement à taire
leurs couleurs à ne pas en parler
donc il ya des sujets gens mais il ya
bien les différences effectivement dont
il faut parler mais il ya des choses qui
n'ont aucune raison d'être
j'aurai le courage appartient à tout le
monde la sensibilité appartient à tout
le monde
l'action appartient à tout le monde et
l'apathie appartient à tout le monde
sortir de ces deux types genre et
concernant nos identités va aussi vous
aider à aborder les idées et notamment
le féminisme avec une autre approche
tout comme les femmes sont encore à bien
des égards considéré comme l'hymne
essentiel en creux par rapport à l'homme
on parle et simone de beauvoir le
deuxième sexe il avait même pour le
féminisme qui est encore trop souvent on
n'a pas beaucoup par rapport aux hommes
c'était un match extraordinaire parce
que comme son nom l'indiqué l'objet du
féminisme c'est pas les hommes alors ça
veut pas dire que les hommes sont
explique les énergies sont bienvenus et
c'est juste pas le sujet en fait c'est
aussi pour cette raison que à titre
personnel pas fan du terme égalité
femmes-hommes parce que j'aime pas le
concept d'égalité dans l'absolu mais
parce que en tant que féministe son
objectif n'est absolument pas d'être
légal d'ailleurs mais d'atteindre ses
standards de masculinité qui on le sait
bien souvent sont très toxiques
d'ailleurs s'ils sont confortablement
plus toxiques ils le sont aussi pour les
hommes c'est évidemment ce sont des
choses qui ne changent pas très
rapidement relation de lantin au
quotidien canton
sur quelque chose de plus court terme je
pense que c'est important aussi de
remettre les choses en contexte le
féminisme n'est pas une déclaration de
guerre
c'est une demande pressante de paix
dragée haute à la guerre je veux juste
qu'on fiche la paix en fait je veux
qu'on me fiche la paix avec les choix
pouvoir faire ce que je veux être qui
j'ai envie d'être faire ce que j'ai
envie de faire peu importe mon genre
arrêté détenu dans une case en
permanence en permanence j'aimerais
aussi qu'on fiche la paix dans la rue
que je sois en mini jupe ou en double
j'aimerais qu'on me fiche la paix parce
que j'ai mieux à faire près de quatre
ans vigilance constante toute ma vie
durant et dire que j'ai mieux à faire ne
veut pas dire que je vais me laisser
faire
je crois qu'on vient de vivre une
période de prise de conscience que
j'espère historique avec l'élection
donald trump déjà qui a donné lieu
partout dans le monde à des successions
de mauvaises marge que récemment les
mouvements mis tout à une oeuvre qui ont
montré que non on va pas accepter ce
qu'on a accepté trop longtemps donc je
ne parle pas d'une bête bisounours mais
ce n'est pas une attaque non plus à
titre personnel
je me suis rendu compte au fil des
dernières années que désamorcer le
conflit
c'est aussi quelque chose qu'on peut
faire un niveau individuel et finalement
ça revient à prendre soin de soi en 2015
ils ont monté une entreprise ses
ministres en 2007 j'ai commencé à
prendre la parole régulièrement sur ces
thématiques
depuis je travaille régulièrement sur
des projets et créatif artistique
engagée autour du féminisme
bref j'ai été féministe à plein temps a
du temps le soir le week-end ça a pris
beaucoup de cases manif et je me suis
rendu compte que quelque chose ait une
vraie leçon est la suivante plus
important finalement ce n'est pas
d'avoir raison
c'est de gagner et ce qui compte ce
n'est pas de gagner contre quelqu'un
mais gagner tout court en ensemble et
pour longtemps
donc une fois qu'on a dit faire ça
nécessite de faire des concessions
souvent même de mettre son orgueil de
côté sa sensibilité de côté et j'avais
ça peut être frustrant
ça peut même être excessivement énervant
d'avoir un amant face de soi qui se sont
symboliquement adressées par les
discours féministe contient depuis ces
derniers mois alors qu'il se rend
problème probablement pas compte qu'il a
en face de lui une femme qui a été
agressée donc là symboliquement mais
elle reste tout court je rappelle que en
terme de harcèlement les transports
c'est à cent pour cent 1
donc ça c'est uniquement une agression
minime je ne parle même pas toutes les
autres je pense que oui toi fais le
travail donc plus ça peut être frustrant
ça peut être énervant mais faire ces
efforts finalement c'est nécessaire tout
simplement parce que ça marche pas que
sa pédagogie fonctionne mieux que
l'énervement et bien sûr je suis
consciente qu encore une fois les femmes
subissent à un double standard où c'est
moins évident c'est moins accepté pour
une femme de s'énerver et de faire
preuve de véhémence voire même parfois
d'une forme de violence verbale mais
malgré tout c'est tout simplement les
rêves de la communication à côté de
s'exciter féministe c'est aussi
communicants donc j'essaie d'appliquer
un peu ce que je dis
dans la sphère personnelle aussi en fait
si je crie sur aperture en face de moi
que je n'explique pas la plus belle part
est infini qui ne comprend rien aux
femmes au féminisme à l'avenir je vais
passer lui non plus je vais sortir
énervé frustré je leur ai perdu du temps
0 avancement et une perte de foi en
l'humanité considérable
donc l'idée c'est vraiment sur un calcul
coût avantage et se dire j'ai deux
situations
quand j'ai ce type de conversation qui
se présentent soit je choisi d'y aller
parce que vraiment c'est important pour
moi parce que je sens mon intuition dit
que la personne en face va être et c'est
pire même pas forcément convaincu mais
au moins il dans les changes ou si je le
sens pas reconnaître les personnes qui
fondamentalement sont convaincus de
toute façon on ne pourra pas s'attendre
ou parce que je ne suis pas disponible
émotionnellement parce qu'être engagé
c'est aussi fatiguant alors vous vous ne
pas y aller c'est dans ce sens que j ai
aussi prendre soin de soi désamorcer le
conflit
finalement c'est aussi très féministe
que de dire oui je me fais passer en
premier et non je n'ai pas mérité même
pour cette cause que je défends depuis
tout petit c'est d'autant plus féministe
est d'autant plus important si cette
cause
si simone as raison tu peux la défendre
toute la vie durant